hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes Titans of
artistic achievement and forces them to
compete for our Amusement that's going
to be a recurring theme today because
we're featuring two of the most amusing
forces planet earth has ever witnessed
and just the heightened attention and
raise the stakes even more our two stars
are real life BFFs
they tell jokes together vacation
together and most recently investigate
murders in their building with fellow
tenant Selena Gomez it's comedy Legend
Steve Martin taking on merriment Maestro
Martin Short right now on versus in one
corner representing America it's Martin
no not that with Steve Martin this is
going to get confusing isn't it Steve
Martin The Versatile funny man who acts
writes and banjos his way all over the
globe oh and he happens to be arguably
the biggest stand-up act in the history
of the art form my real name is uh
just wait until you hear how big the
Uranus he sold out regularly were
although the term Arena kind of puts you
in that mind frame and the other Carter
fighting out of Canada it's Martin Short
The Versatile funny man who acts sings
dances and just might have the most
pound-for-pound laughs of any guest to
ever appear on a late night talk show
speaking of late night these two have
also had their fair share of live
Saturday nights from New York this is
going to be a fun one I must say oh that
certainly would be pleasant a must say
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two Tomato
Meter slash audience score round three
iconic characters round four late night
and then we'll do a Wild Card round that
could be the tie breaker between these
two wild and crazy guys although that
sketch featuring Steve Martin was with
another Canadian Dan Aykroyd it's become
so beloved over the years that it might
be trademarked so we'll stick with
calling these Buddies the Two Amigos and
I'm sure not that Chevy Chase will
emerge at some point
short and Martin which now sounds like a
law firm or an upscale men's clothing
shop actually hit it off while filming
Three Amigos and that 1986 gem would
serve as a launching point for a
friendship that is going stronger than
ever as evidenced by an ongoing tour
starring the two and the hit Hulu show
only murders in the building meanwhile
here on versus it's as competitive as it
gets but we're really just here to
celebrate two legendary careers
dedicated to making people laugh and
occasionally finding out who killed Tim
Kono if it's a tie after four rounds
maybe we call Selena Gomez to determine
the winner she's not available it's all
going to come down to me then your host
Mark Ellis director of sales shower
curtain ring Division I sell shower
curtain rings
best in the world let's get it on round
one box office with two comedy
Superstars as beloved as Steve Martin
and Martin Short one would be correct in
assuming that they've had their fair
share of hit movies sure Martin got his
start in stand up and happened to become
the biggest in the world at it and short
first rose to fame and sketch comedy and
happened to star in arguably the two
biggest sketch shows of all time but
Hollywood beckoned and these funny folks
heeded the call and while both have
starred in plenty of films in their own
right it was Steve Martin leading the
way and the Father of the Bride flicks
with Martin Short supporting as a very
zealous wedding planning Swiss army
knife even though I think he was French
oh yeah
so those two films combined to take in
over 150 million dollars worldwide Three
Amigos would add 39 million dollars to
each his total short and Martin which
still sounds odd each did voices in the
1998 Hit The Prince of Egypt as well
which would amass 218 million dollars
around the globe for Martin Short it's
the voice over work that keeps him
treading water in this round his turn in
Madagascar 3 as Stefano helped that
Juggernaut churn out 746 million dollars
worth of business and The Adams Family
from 2019 tosses 200 mil more on the
pile shorts legendary Jack Frost in the
Santa Claus 3 marks his best performing
live-action role as that movie crossed
the 100 million dollar line with seven
mil despair Mars Attacks and jungle the
jungle also serve as credible hits for
his resume in the mid-1990s and now we
look to Steve Martin who kicked off his
movie stardom career back in 1979 with
the Carl Reiner directed hit the jerk 73
million dollars worldwide is a gaudy
number in any era and it would usher in
a decade of hits including such titles
as Planes Trains and Automobiles Dirty
Rotten Scoundrels and Roxanne though
they were all modest smashes none
crossed the 50 million dollar line but I
give him credit for a memorable pop into
the Muppet movie which earned 76 million
dollars back in 1979. excellent choice
then a decade later Parenthood exploded
with a 126 million dollar take a
harbinger of 1990 successes to come like
the Father of the Bride flicks house
sitter 94 million dollars and both
finger at 98 million bucks once again it
seemed Martin was on the precipice of
another decade on top or even a new
millennium yeah the 2000 saw Steve
Martin make his biggest live-action
splash of the box office ever thanks to
family hits like bringing down the
houses 164 million dollar total and
franchises like Cheaper by the Dozen and
the Pink Panthers dozens is team up for
325 million dollars the Panthers raped
in a combined 228 million bucks
good one all told Steve Martin's highest
grossing movie ever where we get to see
him is the 2009 hit it's complicated
which brought in 224 million dollars
around the world but because Martin's
best animated film home topped out a 385
million dollars could Martin Short steal
round one from his good buddy
we got a chance short career box office
total is an impressive 2.4 billion
dollars making for a per film average of
83 million every time we see or hear him
on the big screen meanwhile Steve Martin
best his bud with a 2.97 billion dollar
total haul but his average is lower
resting at 68 million dollars I've got a
lot to learn about handling my money and
Banks oh boy couldn't one of these cats
just pop into a Marvel or a star war and
make my job easier I imagine these two
good buddies are backstage somewhere
watching this very vid waiting to go on
stage until I render a decision in this
round so if there's an audience waiting
I'll be brief but first may I use the
restroom
course you may thank you Steve Martin's
resume rests more on his leading man
status than Martin shorts does short is
nothing Well short of phenomenal in his
starring roles like Clifford pure luck
and Inner Space but the box office take
simply doesn't reflect that comedic
genius like it does Steve Martin's
Martin's pivot into the more
family-friendly Fair beginning with
Parenthood proves to be the determining
Factor here so by the slimmest of
margins I'm giving the nod to him in
round one the jerk I hate combat because
he seems like such a nice guy wins this
phase and goes up one to nothing all
right boys you can go on stage now have
a great show and if you need an opener
next time I know someone yeah well I'd
love to discuss this with you further
about him expecting someone
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score and here we careen into round two
where the critics and audiences have
their say after their wallets and purses
got to shout in round one Steve Martin
nearly won that round about who walked
into the movie theater now we'll see who
the throngs of admirers liked better on
the way out but I will say I must say
that both jets are going to be sporting
a ton of fresh fare here worthy of their
perch atop comedic Mount Olympus Steve
Martin hot off a big win the previous
round now it looks to keep his momentum
going with a trio of classic flicks that
sit in the 90s on the Tomato Meter
Parenthood is at 91 percent Planes
Trains and Automobiles is at 92 percent
and Steve's best starring role output
here is LA Story at 93 percent with a
critics consensus that reads a romantic
comedy that doubles as a love letter to
the titular City LA's story is Steve
Martin at his silly sweetly Soulful best
is this a joke or something also getting
into a four-year reputable University
according to grades is Dirty Rotten
Scoundrels and Roxanne both are at 88
percent and all of me is at 85 percent
and the jerk keeps the rhythm as best he
can at 83 percent Martin Short's going
to be competitive with his pal here in
the Tomato patch as he has the big
picture and the win Rises both at 88 and
the willoughby's are at 91 interspace
also scores big with an 82 percent and a
critics consensus that says a manic
overstuffed blend of sci-fi comedy and
romance interspace nonetheless charms
thanks to Martin Short's fine
performance and the insistent zaniness
of the plot Short's impeccable comedic
voice pads his average with animated
hits like Frankenweenie at 87 percent
The Spiderwick Chronicles at 81 and
Madagascar 3 is at 78 for funsies our
Dueling Banjos teamed up for Father of
the Bride which is 70 percent father the
bride two at 52 percent and Three Amigos
I don't tell is it right it's rotten uh
it's 45 percent
I'll take it comedy is a sport full of
big swings and mythological home runs
but also some strikeouts for Martin
Short his talent was belied by poor
critical responses to pure luck at nine
percent and Clifford at 13 meanwhile
Steve Martin's foray into all ages Fair
might have served him well in terms of
box office but it put him in the Penalty
Box with some critics as Cheaper by the
Dozen is it 24 and the sequel is the low
Mark for either actor at just six
percent mixed nuts could only season a
13 which ties it with the Pink Panther
2. so it's a close call here and we
might need to see the audience score
before determining a winner in this
round I don't care what anyone says
Jiminy Glick and while I would is
hysterical and it's a prosecutable crime
that is only a 32 percent with you the
good people of Earth and baby Mama's
only at 55 percent that movie's
hysterical and Steve Martin steals every
scene he's in luckily y'all redeemed
yourselves in Steve Marty and my eyes by
making Three Amigos fresh on the
audience score metric with 67 percent
Three Amigos
coincidentally that's also the score for
Clifford and all of me and the highest
ranking effort for either star with the
crowds is a team win as Prince of Egypt
is at 90 all told it's neck and neck
here in round two Martin Short's movie
Tomato Meter average is a fresh 60 per
film his Bud Steve Martin is just south
at 53 percent Steve gets closer to Fresh
town with an audience score average of
58 but Martin Short improves to 61
percent here and yes Martin Short's TV
Tomato Meter is a 67 percent average
compared to Martin's 100 percent but
that 100 percent is solely thanks to
only murders in the building season two
of which is currently underway as of
this filming can't wait to see what the
TM says about that I'm only halfway
through season one as a matter of fact
but I'm pretty sure both of them are
going to survive unless sting gets
really upset thus Martin Short takes a
victory here in round two and all of a
sudden we're tied one to one hey that's
great congratulations round three iconic
characters and now around the that
appears quite often on versus the most
viewed competition show of all time in
certain parts of Virginia I think it's
the best show on the air ever that has
been that's weird how good it is it's so
strange but today iconic characters
seems as though it was custom made just
for Steve Martin and Martin Short yes
their big screen exploits will obviously
count here but I'm also keeping an eye
on their dozens of memorable sketch
Creations on the small screen but enough
Preamble if you've ever seen Steve
Martin as Neil Page and Planes Trains
and Automobiles then you know you
probably shouldn't keep him waiting
especially for a rental car
car right
now I'm told it's not ready yet so we'll
kick off with Martin Short double gobble
in just one season as an SNL cast member
I can already hear my friends to the
north yelling what about SCTV I'm just
setting the table we'll get to you short
Creator the last thing lasts with folks
like Nathan thurm a tobacco grower of
America and Ed Grimley who I must say
shared a few DNA strands with many of
his prior Creations from SCTV the
legendary reason that word a lot today
aren't we Canadian sketch show that
helped make a name for Martin Short
Catherine O'Hara Eugene Levy Rick
Moranis and John Candy just to name a
few legendary
I dare you right now to YouTube Jackie
Rogers and keep a straight face we get
to see a young Martin Short swinging in
the wilderness with disastrously
hysterical results I watched it again
this morning it's better than a strong
cup of joe you're just saying that to
get a higher rating on your TV show
scenes from an idiot's marriage
half-wits it was easy to see why
Saturday Night Live so wanted Martin
Short to come be an All-Star and it's a
shame we only got him for one season
there but SCTV Remains the gift that
keeps on giving I'm having some degree
of difficulty getting through High
School Steve Martin not only inhabited
great characters in his appearances
hosting SNL he provided some all-time
musical bits in his 15 occurrences as
the host he's also popped in as a
surprise many more times and just one
example of his unique Brilliance is when
he's making a simple Christmas wish list
that includes that crap about the kids
but after retiring from stand-up comedy
because I'm checking my notes he got two
famous his big screen breakthrough came
in the form of Nathan Johnson the
supposed son of a family of black
sharecropper is in The Jerk his rhythm
was dancing intimated that he might be
headed on a different path than his
adopted relatives and just like Johnson
Martin had found his purpose in
delighting audiences in movie theaters
with starring roles like a Welsh fireman
in Roxanne and cameos in such hits as
Little Shop of Horrors which is a
hilarious scene unless you're like me
and you actually had a dentist
appointment later that day
[Applause]
Planes Trains and Automobiles holds up
as a holiday classic not just because of
Martin's comedic chemistry with John
Candy but also because of the emotional
beats these two actors Build Together
Steve Martin can be hilarious dressing
down Candy's Del Griffith but then a few
seconds later we feel all the sympathy
in the world for the big guy and we just
want these two to hug it out just make
sure that when you wake up the next day
those are pillows before you get too
comfy those aren't pillows
[Music]
meanwhile Martin Schwartz over the top
Pitch Perfect genius perfectly LED
itself to Inner Space in which a tiny
Dennis Quaid invades his body with knees
slapping results Clifford is another
brilliant display of shorts chops in a
film far too few have seen you think
that Miss Sarah and Mr Ellis perhaps
would name their first child Martin
Marty displays more range in roles like
Mars Attacks and inherent Vice where he
plays a drugged up sleaze ball infected
by paranoia look that movie is not an
easy watch except when short is there
because you just can't take your eyes
off him for all the greatness that Steve
Martin shows and the family hits like
Parenthood and Cheaper by the Dozen he's
still at his best when he has a comedy
Superstar to play off of
hello ladies no I'm not talking about
you Martin I was thinking Eddie Murphy
in Bowfinger Martin is a Hollywood
adjacent B movie director and acting
teacher looking for a hit so he wedges
an unknowing star kit Ramsey into a
sci-fi movie the result is a Timeless
classic whose laughs only seem to get
bigger with each re-watch if the ball
game feels too close to call now let's
have a look at when these two have
shared the screen starting with the
smaller one no spoilers for me because
I'm still in season one but only murders
in the building is a wonderful Series so
far that Nails the chemistry that short
and Martin have honed on stage during
their touring show and the two also
share a perfect third companion with
Selena Gomez it's a compliment to all
three that they can hang with the other
two when it comes to movies it's usually
Steve tolerating Martin as evidence in
the father of the brides Three Amigos
will be a lasting film on the top of
their ographies simply for the sweet
little buttercup performance I thought
we were quite good in it good we were
great but because it was Martin that
broke into film first and in such a
dynamic way with the jerk and then a
string of films in the 1980s I give him
the slight Edge in this round maybe the
most competitive yet but it will be
Steve Martin taking the iconic
characters round and he regains the
advantage two to one
round four late night and now we arrive
at a round that at first blush feels
like another one that Steve Martin can
easily take heck ask anyone today and
they're pretty sure that Steve Martin
was an original cast member of SNL
simply because he was and remains such a
Mainstay of the almost 50-year history
of the program but let's not forget that
Martin Short was a cast member often
Pops in unannounced and steals entire
sketches and is also a delight across
the late night talk show circuit after
perfecting his own wild and crazy Antics
on stand-up stages Martin teamed up with
original SNL cast member Dan Aykroyd for
just one of his many memorable roles on
the show we are foreign
the regular host momentum is carried
Martin through the decades to the point
where now it's a fun riff between him
and Alec Baldwin as they compete for the
title of most guest appearances in
history in an episode a few years back
an opening sketch saw Martin Baldwin and
a few other luminaries like Paul Simon
in an exclusive VIP room celebrating
their achievement as Studio 8h legacies
as they reminisce before an awestruck
audience a waiter happens by to take
drink orders who was it you guessed it
Martin Short sad his time on SNL was
limited to just one year in the
mid-1980s though War has it that Warren
Michaels desperately wanted short to
return with him to form a new core cast
that would take the show into the 1990s
but film TV on the Broadway stage
beckoned so short politely declined and
would go on to become one of the great
late night talk show panelists of all
time in a short list that might also
include Don Rickles Rodney Dangerfield
Robin Williams Martin has submitted
himself as the perfect couch companion
in to a plethora of hosts throughout the
ages everyone from Johnny Carson to
Jimmy Fallon and David Letterman nakonan
and Jimmy Kimmel his lightning quick
reflexes believe his desperate for
approval shtick making his appearances
must-see TV even when he's not
necessarily there to promote anything oh
please and now that Martin and short are
tethered together by a sold out theater
run at a hit streaming show they often
show up as a pair or sometimes a trio
with Selena Gomez in a recent episode of
Jimmy Kimmel Live it was short and Gomez
Who warmed the couch and then they
opened a briefcase where a virtual Steve
Martin was waiting via Zoom short
playfully enjoyed absolute power over
his dear friend and as always came
equipped with topical jokes and
self-deprecating uppercuts
thank you so much the two energies are
so different which is what makes such a
potent Elixir when they're together sure
Martin Short can play it straight and
set his fellow performer up for a gag
and Steve Martin can hearken back to his
1970s days anytime he wants to display
an unrivaled burst of energy but for all
the many memories the both of them have
made a 30 Rockefeller Center the
unmatched win and timing of Martin Short
when he's appearing anywhere after hours
is a guaranteed good time much like the
talk show host that he leaves in
stitches us the audience are laughing
just as hard and as often with him as
with anyone who's ever been on those
hallowed couches no one can possibly
replace Steve Martin as an SNL Legend
he's a one of a kind trick who so blends
with the weekly insanity and delivers
the Saturday night payoff as well as
anyone ever has but now it's Martin
Short who continues to transcend
generation gaps and make a new crop of
talk show hosts gasp for air as he
continues to spit out comedy gold at an
unrivaled clip Martin Short takes round
four and we're all tied up at 2-2 as as
we head into around custom made for
these two thank you
and now it's time for the Wild Card
round Legacy what's amazing about Martin
Short and Steve Martin's late night
Legend status is that's still just
scraping the surface of their hilarity
footprint that they've left each
performer has been making us howl with
laughter for so long their combined
lineage in the Limelight would surpass a
Century's worth of joke telling but
whose Legacy is richer when it all comes
down to it I asked that question mainly
as one last desperate attempt to bat
signal Selena Gomez so she can come in
and do this round and I won't have to
make a choice between Steve Martin and
Martin Short I feel like the mom at the
end of The Good Son
Steve Martin began a career in
entertainment just down the road from
this very Studio at Southern
California's Knott's Berry Farm where
he'd perform self-taught magic tricks
and pepper in an occasional joke then
the stand-up comedy boom happened just
as he was finding his footing as a
writer for shows like the Smothers
Brothers as good as that day job was
there was something so freeing about
being a solo act at nightclubs luckily
for all of us Steve Martin heeded that
call Martin Short attended University in
Canada with plans to become a social
worker but after being cast into local
production he decided to serve the
people in a very different way that
production was Godspell and also in that
cast happened to be Gilda Radner Eugene
Levy and Dave Thomas and the musical
director you guessed it long time
Letterman bandleader Paul Schaefer
imagine how tough a ticket to that show
would be today from those Beginnings
arose two Mighty comedy legacies that
are now intertwined but if Martin Short
was the Victor in a late night TV round
it might be Steve Martin that has the
advantage here why remember that
stand-up thing he was going to give a
try he happened to to become arguably
the biggest comedy act in the history of
Earth blending a kinetic style chock
full of irreverent jokes and sarcastic
wit and adding in a dash of Andy
kaufman-like Singularity Steve Martin
would go to tour Arenas when comedy
clubs were springing up across the
country when other Comics were doing
weekends at those clubs he was selling
out stadiums his albums went platinum
and he was so big that the famed Blues
Brothers opened for him at the Los
Angeles Forum doing the arena where the
Lakers play is challenging enough now
imagine having to follow the musical
comedy of John Belushi and Dan Aykroyd
as he Details In His Brilliant biography
born standing up Steve Martin eventually
got so famous that he couldn't go
anywhere do anything lest he invoke a
Beatles Hard Day's nightlike scenario on
the city streets the gigantic Halls were
the only places it was safe to perform
but he no longer felt like he was the
groundbreaking comic that got him there
the audiences were too busy partying and
yelling out beloved lines for him to
generate any new material the intimate
comedy shows had given way to sing-along
rock concerts so Martin had to shift
gears into the next phase of his career
film meanwhile Martin Short was forming
a groundbreaking sketch show called SCTV
with some of his Godspell Pals just like
National Lampoon's Second City and
eventually SNL here in the states SCTV
marked the dawn of a new generation of
comedy and with it a new delivery system
hilarious sketches intertwined with gag
advertisements and set pieces if you
watch any hit comedy from the 80s or 90s
or even today Vegas is going to give you
good odds that it includes some SCTV
fingerprints
so it does only seem fitting that the
Stars aligned literally to bless us with
Martin Short and Steve Martin performing
together on tour late night couches and
on our streaming devices their own
individual legacies are so set in
precious stone thus the only way to
forge ahead to Higher Ground is together
and while it's short that might be
quicker on the draw by the design of
their friendship the advantage Steve
Martin has is that no one ever matched
him in terms of sheer rock star comedian
status others have come close to selling
that amount of tickets but only Eddie
Murphy could throw his hat in the ring
for being that big for that long luckily
we also got to see them team up together
in a film worthy of their talents with
Bowfinger I'm keeping it together I'm
k-i-t-k keep it together I'm keeping it
together right now keep it together keep
it together keep it together keep it
together I'm keeping it together Steve
Martin hasn't done traditional stand up
since his Heyday with one notable
exception a few years back he lost a bet
to his buddy Jerry Seinfeld to honor the
debt Jerry mandated that Steve had to
open for him at Carnegie Hall a man of
his word the night came the show was
sold out the lights went down and a
stunned crowd watched the man the myth
himself walk out on the boards to tell
some jokes it was brief to be sure but
the Ovation Steve Martin received that
night was like none other a crowd lucky
enough to witness the Afterglow of a
comet maybe never to be seen again Steve
Martin wins the Legacy round and thus
takes the match and that kids is just
about as close to an emotional Crescendo
as my cold dead heart will allow I play
the same sport that Steve Martin did
Once Upon a Time stand-up comedy but the
level to which his game Rose remains
unmatched and now when I find myself
back in the hotel room after performing
for considerably less folks than Martin
used to I'll be channel surfing until I
find a late night couch occupied by
Martin Short who reminds us just how how
funny he still is after all these years
it was an impossible task today I picked
a winner and I hope everyone watching
enjoys the positive spirit with which
the job was done I don't care if you
agree with me I might wake up tomorrow
and change my mind but I would like you
all to take your own walk down the
hallowed Halls of Comedy greatness and
take in some sketches stand up films
books or anything else that Martin Short
and Steve Martin have delighted us with
over the decades only murders in the
building is actually a pretty good place
to start make sure you keep it right
here at Rotten Tomatoes for the latest
and all things entertainment and for my
stand-up tour dates you can head to Mark
ellis.lot thanks for watching versus my
sweet little buttercups this wild and
crazy guy had a great time I must say